[Music]
hi everyone i'm grandmaster stevens irk
fit today's endgame lecture i'm gonna be
talking about pressing in the endgame
pressing specifically referring to
creating winning chances and winning
better but not winning and not simple in
games so far too often i see players
even pretty strong ones tend to throw
away much better positions like this now
they don't take the endgame seriously
they don't look for the best chances so
in this position for example this is a
very complicated kind of rook endgame
this 3vs3 the outside passer it's drawn
with perfect play but it's quite
difficult actually give rats keys and
game manual covers it varies very
thoroughly very well and even some top
players have miss played it but in any
case it requires a lot of work to draw
if if played correctly but when I saw a
22 couple 2,200 to play out this endgame
last year and they didn't take it
seriously so in the game black just
rushed this pawn down to b2 which kills
a lot of his chances trade it off a
bunch of King side pawns and got nowhere
and the game was a great drawing shortly
after actually white could have been a
little better the reality the better way
to try you push the pawn to b3 and you
threaten to swing the King over and this
creates chances of promoting the pawn or
winning the rook in exchange for one or
two Kings side bonds white can often
draw by creating counter play on the
Kings side but it's very difficult
there's really no risk for black which
is one of the most important parts and
of course plenty of winning chances but
again black played this before b3 b2
almost immediately which I see a lot in
end games so we're gonna talk a bit
basic about how to avoid that about how
difficult things are for the defender if
you play them well so my first example
I'm gonna cover one of the most famous
and game wins one of these technical and
game grinds and this example is actually
from the 2013 World Championship between
Anand and Carlsen so in this game skip
it
Karlsson got a very slightly better
endgame
and we're gonna skip ahead to here so in
this position a little bit before the
endgame an on played a fairly natural
move queen g4 I can't even really fault
it because the potential edge Carlsen
gets is so small in this position after
queen g4 black and played Bishop takes
c3 which forces white to double the
pawns white can't play rook a to work
eight and rook III because F 2 is
hanging so white has to play F takes e3
again Anand was perfectly aware of this
I doubt even considered it a problem
because oftentimes in these middle games
these double D pawns are not a weakness
at all black will sometimes play Bishop
e6 and willingly offer white to double
the Z pawns but Carlsen men just defined
through a very careful calculated play
some great ways of exploiting this so
perhaps in the future it would be better
for white to just play Queen e2 and now
there's never gonna be any double pawns
symmetrical structure again you can play
on but the draw should not be too far
away of course though I shouldn't
insinuate that white has any kind of
serious problem here
even this is even calling this equals
plus would be extremely optimistic Queen
e7 again Queen e6 as I mentioned
straight forward draw but not what
Carlson is interested in a lot of times
you'll see players grandmasters even top
grandmasters agree to draws in positions
like this but there is a lot of untapped
potential especially at the lower levels
queenie 7 c5 and so right now these
eight pawns aren't even very weak right
this black pawn is blocking them the
front pawn which is usually the weaker
one is well defended so the first thing
Carlsen does is push this pawn to c4 so
one way or another
this forces the white pawn away from d3
which means this eforp on suddenly
becomes a potential weakness and Nan
correctly plays d4 if he takes them
potentially this b2 and then c3 pawn can
also be weak and he plays d4 he really
only has one point we
pawns still to work to worry about right
now Carlson can't do anything about it
just yet might look like he can win upon
by taking on d4 but quite simply trades
and then wins his pawn back check and
rip be eight and black has less than
nothing here if anything lights a little
better so no immediate way to punish
again there shouldn't really be a way to
punish but the potential is there right
even though this is quote-unquote an
easy draw and an equal position
why would always take having this F pawn
on f2 on this a pawn on f2 if possible
so it plays rook d1 and this is what we
see in a lot of these end games I would
say safer is d5 and what this does is it
closes off the C file black can't play
this which means the e4 pawn is much
harder to attack but I can potentially
attack this pawn from the diagonal but
as long as white controls these files
it's very difficult for the rook to get
any pressure on White's position and of
course this one Queen attack will be
easy for way to defend a tricky one but
still nuns not in any significant
trouble as of yet that's part of why
these end games are dangerous Anand is a
very strong defender even by super GM
standards Anand is a very strong
defender so fact that even he here even
he can slip up bit by bit
shows you how dangerous these slightly
worse end games can be for just about
any player so rook d1 Queen c6 if black
black could take immediately there's the
potential for this after rook takes d6
is hanging and if Queen c6 or Rocky six
white has this rook d5 when suddenly the
b5 pawn can be just as weak as the e
pawn so Carlsen doesn't take on d4 just
yet and he ran on probably should have
taken his last chance to play d5
so queen c6 Queen f5 again you probably
didn't consider considered this position
to be any serious danger takes and rook
takes force to defend the pawn rookie
five so we see now that this time white
hasn't gotten the chance to pile up on
this fifth rank and on this b5 pawn so
here again the d6 pawn is weak but as
we'll see in the game actually one weak
pawn is better than two weak bonds so
here Carlsen just has the advantage this
is seven and now we're gonna enter a bit
of a maneuvering stage this is very
common in in games one very nice thing
about better end games from the
attackers perspective is that there's
very little danger no it's not like a
pawns upon race for example where a
small slip can be a disaster or an
attacking race with opposite side cos of
the Kings you know in those cases one
side might be better even winning but
they're one bad move away from getting
crushed in these end games there's very
little chance for the defender and
psychologically that actually means that
the defending player is likely to get
frustrated try and force things and slip
and a nod actually does this here so
here equals plus is a pretty fair
evaluation and black is clearly better
but of course still aways from a win so
Carlsen improves his position bit by bit
there's just pawns forward and here
Anand makes what I would say the first
serious slip so he plays Queen g3 he
could have simply basically held the
position as is of course black has no
way of actually winning this e4 pawn
right now black school isn't to try and
win the pawn which is impossible but to
keep the threats on the e4 pawn while
also creating other ideas so he ties
White's pieces down to e4 but blacks not
tied down to e4 at any point he could
switch and try and invade with his rook
and queen on the first rank he could
turn on to b2 instead that's the
advantage of weakness as long as black
attacks
efore white has to defend it but it's
blacks decision when to stop attacking
this week
so Anand and as defenders will often do
tries to force simplification you know
he doesn't like the idea of defending a
position like this for another 40 moves
which is the attackers prerogative so he
tries to force complications bg3 and one
thing this does is it creates another
idea of rook d5 but carlson gets his
extra pawn now while he gets the extra
pawn anan gets a very active rook which
was no doubt his idea so here a white
still has pretty good compensation for
the pawn after rook d5 black is forced
into a defensive stance so this is still
of course drawn but Carlson has a clear
advantage now an advantage that won't go
away and he can look to do what he was
doing before which is bit by bit step up
his position keep creating problems for
Anand who importantly can't really do
anything here you know unlike an
opposite side Kings castling opposite
side castling Attack Position unlike
something like that White has no active
plan here he can't create any passed
pawns he can't create any threats so an
odd just has to sit tight and see what
Carlsen is going to come up with and
that's why being able to press in these
end games is so important if you
remember that first example black out a
much larger advantage than Carlson has
here that no idea how to use it and
didn't take the time to figure it out so
being able to press in positions like
this of course even if you don't always
win them it's worth a lot of points d6
and again blacks rook is stuck to b5 if
I can always return but black can
gradually pushes kingside pawns here
Carlsen makes a bit of a slip please
King f7 this allows anon to simplify a
bit tactically Carlsen should have
played h5 when the basic idea is that
his rook will ultimately be freed if the
work goes to d5 Carlsen transfers his
king to d6 and this rook will have no
squares left on the fifth-ranked so
black starts freeing up his position but
of course White's rook can swing around
to g8 among other things he can try and
trade pawns on the King side still
plenty going on here but this was the
way to go
so king f7 allowing h5 on sacrifice from
Anand and all-in-all it improves his
chances because even though blacks got
into extra ponds now they're very bad
extra pawns of course black would much
rather have a cheap on here and they're
very hard to make use of still very much
we're still very much in the realm of a
draw and of course there's the nice fact
that with this f5 Square open this
maneuver and this h5 squared this
maneuver of taking the rook off the
fifth-ranked
isn't here anymore so f5 blacks only
real try otherwise he can't make
progress without just giving up the b5
pawn and now he does rookie 6 to
gambling the pawn it's forced but the
advantages of course he's got this
second pawn that's well placed and
blacks King side pawns are going to
press faster than White's going to press
this Queen side bonds
and so here I actually like Nakamura
suggestion just play b3 and even though
black can win both these Queen side
pawns we get actually an improved
version of rook and F and H pawn which
is a theoretical draw if you take away
the h6 and g2 pawns this is a drawn
position and this is actually an
improved version of it because it'll
take some work for black to even trade
off these two pawns so white could have
reached this still difficult but noam
draw an endgame and that would have been
a safer way to go but it's possible
Anand still didn't think too much of the
dangers here and indeed he still of
course shouldn't lose this and so he
gives up the chance for b3 a bit more
maneuvering Karlsson's just gradually
pressing forward and here rook g8 I'd
say a bit of a waste of time if you play
rook c8 keeps things difficult for black
alright the rook has to defend the pawn
which makes King out for more difficult
and you have time to swing the rook
around attack this age takes pawn rook
g8 on the other hand since you can't go
into the pawn endgame it's really just a
waste of time but an ons idea probably
was that now after King F for the c4
pawn is indefensible so he does win the
pawn but perhaps he underestimated the
dangers even here
he's reestablished material equality but
this F pawn is going to very rapidly
become a dangerous force just White's
King is badly placed to deal with it why
it's rook is badly placed to deal with
it so we can talk about Anand misjudging
how to handle this rook endgame but the
truth of it is he should never have had
to worry about this in the first place
this often comes up in these end games
right your position is just a tiny bit
worse maybe an equal but you slip a
little bit of course you're not giving
anything away the engine might still
very well read zero zero zero but now
all of a sudden you need to find the
careful moves you need to find the
difficult defenses I mean even this
position again as a draw but it's much
worse for white than the initial in the
end
position was to f4 and rook a4 and again
this is actually a game losing blunder
and the mere fact that a move which is
pretty natural reasonable in this
position you want to get the rook out of
the pawns way you can swing it back here
or up here the fact that a natural move
like this loses the game tells you how
critical White's position has gotten you
know even though it's objectively a draw
it's a even though objectively it's a
drawn position it's a much worse
position than it was before because
White has to be so careful and it turns
out that by playing b4 White essentially
gets counter play fast enough so there's
a lot of specifics here I'm not going to
go too in depth of them the more general
point is that white would have to read
all this correctly and carefully just to
earn the draw that he should have had in
the first place but the the idea is if
black tries this rook e1 basically to
free up his King so we can push the pawn
forward which is the winning idea in
general white can trade and because he's
advanced this pawn far enough with both
sides promote draw but that's the key
white that line is literally just in
time for white white promotes just in
time so when he loses a tempo it's too
late so blacks axis H pawn to create
this past F pawn and even though White's
up material now the quality of this F
pawn which is most of the way and well
supported by its King matter is much
more than the two white pawns there that
are much slower c4 and there's Noth
nothing works for white at this point if
white goes tries to trap the King on the
F file then this rook e1 maneuver will
win because White's too slow
check
so here white has these checks which is
often a drawing technique in these end
games actually this would be much better
for white if these two pawns were gone
but after check and King F for these
pawns actually just get in White's way
and if he goes rook a1 trying to stop
the pawn now that the Kings up here
black wins tactically rookie six
threatening rook you wanted to promote
and after King g2 rookie one way
crucially has no check on the side now
king of four rook e8 going for a last
tactic black wanders and promotes why
it's got the skewer on f8 but rook g1
and the pawn is going through rook jacks
King III and there's nothing I can do
further checks but I can just take these
bonds or even hide behind them and then
promote his own pawn so here are non
resigned so what's the lesson from this
again the game losing move and the move
that gets the question mark in the books
is rook a4 right because with b4 white
had to draw but with rook a 4-way it
lost but the seeds of defeat were sown
way before this white should never have
had to decide whether to play b4 or okay
for again both look pretty reasonable in
this position should never have had to
calculate this whole line up to b6
you know this nine move variation just
to draw none of that should ever have
been required of white in the first
place and if white had avoided these
slips before so going back I would say
the biggest one just this Queen g3
giving black this endgame in the first
place there's a couple others even
though it's still drawn it's difficult
and everyone makes mistakes in difficult
positions sometimes and conversely
looking from the attackers perspective
being able to create those kind of
problems is so valuable because so often
I mean Anand again who is a world-class
defender even by super GM standards can
slip in an endgame like this which means
just about everyone else can too
so the key is the attacker
so really thinks things through first of
all wicket moves that create problems
for your opponent of course the position
is drawn
you know Carlson knew that you didn't
think this was winning but he's creating
threats that an on has to figure out how
to accurately deal with and he really
has nothing to lose there's very little
play for white in this position he just
has to make sure not to blunder this b5
bond or a lot way create threats against
it of course everything is on Carlsen
side psychologically all right so to
continue from that I'm gonna show one of
my own games I've had a few successes in
similar end games just like this this
one is particularly important because I
actually played it last year in a GM
Norma ven Charlotte and as it turns out
I just made the cut for my final GM norm
and ultimately the title so this win of
course proved very crucial so in this
position I was playing black Black has a
tiny advantage due to the isolated pawn
if white takes with the F pawn then King
sides a little weak neither one of
course should objectively be a serious
problem for white and when there's this
when there's only one piece like this
black has no good way of really applying
pressure to this deep on so the fact
that it's weak means very little it just
means that White's queen is on defensive
duty which again is nice for black but
black has no possible try to actually
win it it just means as positions a bit
more comfortable an equals Plus would
again be a pretty optimistic evaluation
here queen c6 but as we're going to see
what tends to happen in these positions
and again in equal positions a lot of
players even strong ones and couch sign
is a strong I am even strong ones will
tend to play slowly you know they won't
respect the danger of the position they
won't they'll just kind of sit there and
let you press a bit and a bit more and
the reality is they should be playing
active so he did he did start with a
good active move he played Queen c3 not
a trivial move because this pawn endgame
after Queen takes c3 requires some
calculation
so it does take some work to play a move
like this but it's very good that he
worked it out
worked out correctly that the pawn
endgame is drawn and basically went for
as much as he could from the position
you know I could simply play a move like
Queen d2 and just sit on defensive duty
and of course Queen d2 isn't losing it's
not even a real serious blunder the
computer won't give it any kind of issue
at all because White's still in that
threshold of a draw but the reality is
White's position is slipping up bit by
bit and when you play a move like that
and a lot of players will do that and
I've won a few games off of it and it's
worth figuring out how to create play
when your opponent does something like
that
so Queen d6 you know just to look at
this a bit the gist of it is White's
King gets active just in time even
though black takes up a slightly better
post that gets the d5 but after c-4
check and basically black has no way to
break through you can play b5 but
White's king holds him off on both sides
black go stay for white covers on b2 and
there's no way for black to get through
into White's position again took some
calculation but actually doing that and
putting an effort into end games which a
lot of players don't do is very
important because now white does have
the C file which helps out a bit
wouldn't see a check actually don't like
this as much it looks a bit active but
everything in blacks position is secure
and since black can take d4 with no
repercussions that White's queen is just
gonna have to go back and defend so this
won't achieve anything why it's
basically just improving blacks King
with tempo it's chasing blacks King
forward where it wants to go anyway and
then it's going to return back over here
to defend this pawn so better I would I
would like better is something like say
g4 and now if black wants to make any
play press sport on the King side for
example he's forced to trade another
pair of pawns which makes the defensive
task that much easier
again not a serious wonder or anything
the computer like I said will not
complain about it at all but it just
means that the margins are a bit in
there
when they were before king f7 queen b7
check King g6 we have blacks King again
a little happier than it was before
Queen check f5 King f7 and so now here
it's a bit trickier white doesn't really
have g4 anymore and f4 with the same
idea of restricting blacks pawns creates
some weaknesses in the position again it
and it also creates this potential
invasion route for blacks King which
means that pawn end games are a lot
riskier so Queen c3 and now bit by bit
black starts to create advantages in the
position
g58 4 so White's stabling as Queen side
which is fine in King g7 I would say
that in general you want to be looking
at ways to improve your position it's
too late to improve them the King side
bonds improving the Queen side bonds is
fairly useful I would have centralized
the King a bit earlier e 2 and f4 and
this isn't a great winning attempt there
isn't a great winning attempt here
because blacks advantage is still quite
small but black does need to find a way
to move forward here sooner or later
everything in whites position is well
defended you're not going to create any
passed pawns therefore sunny winds off
the bat so you need to look for a way to
create complications and any kind of
advantage you can and it's still not
even equals plus yet but after f4 we do
get one nice thing if white takes now
these two outside pawns mean that black
has the possibility of creating a past
h-bomb and if this pawn on f5 black
would have a much harder time creating
winning chances act in this position
again I think this is the time now
before things are critical for white to
calculate and come up with more
aggressive more optimistic more greedy
moves so queen d3 here for example
and then whites creating strong
counterplay this is the downside of f4
now this diagonal is open and
importantly now black has problems to
solve - black has to be a little careful
just white can win some pawns black has
to make sure you know he doesn't lose
pawns and suddenly become worse black
might blunder there so psychologically
that's also very useful if we play moves
like this your opponents have to worry
and in better positions better end games
they often don't
for example after G takes green takes
with these more passed pawns and this
weak bond on d4 black has nothing to
worry about here
his only question is how good of a
winning chance can I create or
conversely after Queen d3 black has to
watch out that he doesn't suddenly give
white something on the Kings side so G
takes Queen takes a bit passive problem
is blacks careful not to give white any
checks and white can't go after this b6
pawn because d4 will cover b63 and this
is makes sense
the idea of f3 is now black can't create
a passed pawn on h3 if you plays g4 y
will just capture so I think the best
move here the one downside is now all of
a sudden this pawn on g2 is a bit weaker
and black games to punish that so h4
Queen B 5 alright what the idea of now
if Queen takes d4 since there's no f5
pawn white can take this pawn with check
and suddenly White's down a weak bond y
can offer a queen trade here because the
opponent game is fine so instead of that
black plays Queen g3 and I actually
don't like the white allowed this the
problem now with f3
white doesn't have a great way to defend
g2 if King f1 h3 so taking here loses
both pawns actually it's even worse if
black goes here
if white goes here black checks and
whichever way white goes black can
capture one of these pawns with Jack and
then it will be a winning endgame so
here we're starting to see that white
does have some problems to solve after
Queen g3 just suddenly as King's side is
weakened so actually going back after
h4 again white should have played queen
d3 with the idea that after queen g3
king f1 h3 doesn't work anymore because
f3 is defended this Queen I would say is
very well placed on d3 it covers all the
weak bonds and it has potential counter
play on h7 after Queen b5 which the idea
is nice right white wants to create
counter play on blacks King side the
problem is it's just much too slow
because blacks had all this time to
advance as pawns during which white
hasn't achieved nearly as much blacks
threats are going to come in first this
H fourth pawn is a much stronger threat
than any of White's bonds it's three
moves from queening and only one pawn
Stanton stands in its way so Queen b5
it's the right idea but it's too late
now after Queen g3 now white is in some
serious trouble
King f1 again fails to h3 when White's
going to be down a pawn at least course
the attempt to defend by Queen e2 is a
disaster after each - so it's too late
at this point for white to defend the
position he'll lose a pawn if he tries
so he has to go for this counter play
but again as I said since blacks the one
who's been improving more before blacks
play comes in first which especially in
end games whoever has the better past
pawn as we saw in the Carlsen game as
well whoever has the better past pawn
tends to win because the threat of
creating a queen is so dominant in the
endgame it's far stronger than anything
else
so when g1 check here I play a bit of
cat-and-mouse just gradually deciding
where to place my Queen say this is a
good psychological trick in end games if
your opponent can't really do much in
response you just bait them around a bit
you make them take some time get a bit
nervous about wandering this works with
Queens because the Queen can just
maneuver around the King so effectively
a lot of times if they're passive and
rook or minor piece end games you can
just kind of shuffle between threats
even if none of them are winning you
know just make it's much more likely
that they'll make a mistake than you
will
and same idea Queen just shuffles around
in the end I settle on this square on f4
or it's well centralized and start to
push my pawn and you can see just how
dangerous this pawn already is it's two
steps from queening it's actually hard
to stop for the king because the Queen
against the king is so powerful if the
King can't stop a Queen and pawn it'll
actually it made a difference so here
white already needs to find an immediate
tactical solution and so the main
defensive idea in Queen endgames
is perpetual check now the King side
pawn advance did weaken blacks King so
there is a plausible threat of perpetual
check here and that's why white should
seek and so here much like the critical
rook a four versus b4 position in a non
Carlsen here was actually White's
critical moment so we can talk about how
white blundered here instead of finding
the unique defense but I think the much
more interesting blunders were the
earlier ones these Queen checks that
gave black time to start pushing his
pawns the lack of playing g4 it's a
restrict blacks King side advance the
earlier failing to play Queen d3 which
would have stopped this whole Queen g3
maneuver all of those I consider much
more important blunders guess there is a
tactical solution here but it's quite
difficult to find and it very well might
not be there at all you want to you want
to stop things way before these concerns
come up and here the unique draw for
white was Queen b7 check when blacks
King doesn't have any great ways to go
so for example King f6 is the best try
but the key here is after Queen c8 again
there's really no shelter if h2 White
has a perpetual check if King g7 not
Queenie sex which allows this pawn to
advance forward but Queen d7 check is
the key black can't trade Queen's even
though this pawn is advanced White's
King will be in time to stop it which
means that black really has nothing good
here because this queen is on d7 it's
threaten you to take on e6 of King f6
Queen d8 just maintains the checks and
otherwise black has no moves
so if light were to play queen c8 or in
this position I'd find something else
because black is too slow to advance the
pawn yeah it's drawn but same thing the
nice side of a better endgame you can
keep pressing so instead white plays
Queen a7 check and again the fact that
this is the difference between a drawn
position and a lost one tells you how
much white position the white position
has declined so King f6 the key here
being if white goes for the same kind of
perpetual after Queen AAA he's still
threatening the draw with checks here so
black plays King g7 but crucially a
white doesn't have Queen d7 Jack he has
Queen b7 check after which black simply
plays King 8 chicks and there's no Queen
e6 and there and no perpetual the way
can fight on Wieck and try and create
threats but this is lost so instead he
takes on a five again the same idea
largely of going for counter play the
problem is this h-bond is much better
than the two white Queen side pawns
similar to the anon Carlsen game again
quality of past bonds means so much in
these end games especially Queen end
games so white is threatening Queen d8
check black goes here there's some
problems here
if King g7 Queen e7 check and it's still
difficult to stop the jacks so black
first improves his Queen and the d4 it's
not about winning the pawn winning the
pawn is irrelevant here black's whole
goal is to promote this pawn for which
you know he would gladly give up both of
these bonds and give away the d4 pawn
back it's not about the pawn it's about
improving the position of the Queen and
from this d4 square the Queen stops all
kinds of checks it's prepared to give
some nasty checks to the white king and
it covers a lot of other important
squares
it's Queen a8 again what's trying to
create counterplay the pawns aren't
important the threats of Perpetual and
the threats of this skewer mean too much
more and here why it's already lost but
I actually slipped this endgame is still
difficult for both sides with the
Queen's on it's very tactical and very
sharp a lot of it depends on carefully
avoiding perpetual check ideas and so
the way to win was to do something we
saw a bit earlier King g7 Queen b7 check
again no Queen d7 no threat on e6 King
h6 and if you check light has no
perpetual because of this key idea this
is actually a nice feature the white
king is badly placed on e 2 so why can't
take this h2 pawn
thanks to this skewer and we'll see that
come up again later in the game after
Queen Czech Queen f6 the Czechs will run
out very soon so that was the key this
Queen is already very well placed this
is another time when I tried to play
cat-and-mouse
you know just shuffle around a bit I
figured I could always change my Queens
position by checking the king which is
common in these end games but the
mistake here is that this idea of toying
with your opponent trying to create
practical threats it doesn't make sense
when you're already winning right black
can promote the pawn here black and push
it through so there's no reason to try
and trick white or create difficulties
just win the game so Queen B to King you
on and it's still not easy it's very
difficult for white to defend but
objectively white did have a defense and
here after Queen c2 Czech White had this
very nice idea of King F 1
so the idea is first of all if black
carelessly checks for example if black
goes here oh I can start to approach the
pawn or what black can just sit on the F
file and of course here why it's not
going to go here wander into a tragic
checkmate
it's just going to sit here and the key
point this King here is that the King
can stop this black pawn so for example
if in this position after h2 White has a
perpetual I mean a difficult one but a
perpetual because any Queen trade is
actually bad for black black won't lose
the pawn endgame okay so there is a
small advantage to having these pawns
wherever black goes if white can check
on the c4 for example or eat for as long
as white retains the move at the end
white will play King G to win this pawn
in the game so here the best move is
actually King f1 again still difficult
but it shouldn't have the opportunity
shouldn't have been allowed instead y
played King III looks a bit better the
King stays active but it's not as good
the problem is blacks queen gets to
activate itself again and find the best
square track a bit more cat-and-mouse
now with the Queen on c2 I decided to
play King g7 one nice feature of this c2
Queen is that it stops a lot of diagonal
checks among other things it can also
check from a lot of squares and maneuver
to wherever I need to be to cover things
defensively check g6 Queen a8 and
there's still practical difficulties
here right there's all kinds of
possibilities perpetual track or maybe
skewers on the H file but objectively
black should be winning so I check all
the way to b6 to cover these seventh
ranked checks and play King g7 weeny 8
and h2 another nice feature of this this
is where you just have to calculate
again the nice feature of having the
pawn here on h2 is white can't capture
it if white plays Queen takes h2 black
will win with Queen B to check so i
checks a bit and we have to be careful
before you play h2 of course you need to
calculate that the King does in fact
escape the checks it's crucial that the
Queen also defends this e6 pawn and
blacks King basically slips out through
the center bit by bit I mean a fake
check if Queen h8 King at 5 there is one
try to watch out for Queen h8 v Queen h3
you know you have to watch out not king
e5 and Queen takes HT to check which
would be a disaster but King g6 what's
out of checks and he still can't take on
h2
of course you have to calculate all this
in advance but after this King goes to
d5 and whites actually out of checks
again thanks to this nice queen position
and again there's not much for white to
do here white plays King f1 but after
check white can't play king g2 to stop
the promotion because Queen g1 just
forces the king away with mate
so King f2 is forced and here black has
to make one last check of course it's
something to promote the pawn but even
with two queens if there's a perpetual
check there's nothing doing so you can
calculate a lot of variations here but a
simpler way to realize the win and what
I thought of is the king can march to
this a1 square and wherever white checks
from with the black King on a1 black can
either block with Queen B to check or
Queen a to check so there's nothing I
can do wherever as Queen is on the board
with waxing on a1 white is lost and it
doesn't take much to realize that
White's Queen does has no way of
stopping this King March it just doesn't
have enough squares so black promotes
and after 1 check here again y could
give a few more checks but the King's
just going to run over here and there's
nothing I can do so here why it was I'm
alright so let's look it back at that
again briefly so we can talk about
there's a couple tactical mistakes
actually this Queen a7 and again a lot
of times if you look in a book you know
read some annotations it'll say Oh Queen
a7 was the losing move and it's true
Queen a7 was the move that crossed the
line from a draw to a loss but we've
been inching closer and closer to that
line over the last 15 moves and that's
really what matters white should never
have had to decide between Queen a7 and
Queen B so that's why it's so important
as a defender to get as much as you can
to defend accurately and play carefully
right from the start yeah and if white
had played
if white had played here for example G
for blacks kingside pong offensive would
have been stunted and it would have been
much harder to create winning chances so
that's really the way to defend these
end games well and the way did to press
in them you want to take as much as you
can course you have to be careful you
know you have to make sure you don't
blunder upon to some sequence of Queen
checks you have to be careful but beyond
that you should go for as much as you
can try to create as many problems as
you can black tried to create this past
pawn on the H file which again should
was defensible but ultimately proved
successful
it created practical chances you know
playing king f7 King g8 are offering a
draw all three of those things plate
doing that or pushing the King side
pawns both objectively are drawn but one
of them makes your opponent solve
problems this again this is what Carlsen
is an absolute master of the fact that
he did it to someone of a non strength
is insane you know a lot of even super
gems have agreed to draws in positions
like that and that's the key idea is
there's a lot of points to be made in
end games like this but you have to put
some work into it and all too often I
see like in that first example you know
I'll see players just playing the most
automatic moves they won't take time and
then games they'll take it for granted
that their draws unless there's some
crushing advantage and they won't really
know how to handle them so there's a lot
of good examples out there Carlson's got
another famous win against Rob of and a
couple others but the key is you create
practical threats see how much you can
take and really make your opponents
solve problems and calculate variations
and conversely if you're on the defense
you want to take as much as you can you
want to set up as strong a position as
you can before your opponent does this
to you again something like g4 you know
g4 draws Queen c8 draws but one of them
eases the future defensive task by quite
a bit and that's what you want to look
for again these aren't moves the engine
will say is winning but their moves that
will win you games
and yeah that's all I have thank you
very much
you
[Music]
you